here we go I'm very excited today to be
talking again with one of the smartest
guys in fpv Ryan Harrell Ryan did some
interviews with me a little while ago
where we talked about motor kV and motor
theory and Ryan that's something you
really excel at because of your
experience with your website mini quad
test bench where you test motors in so
much detail and you reached out to me
after I did my video with the 6s 2700 kV
quote-unquote 160 mile an hour
quadcopter and I say quote unquote
because it's not legal to go over a
hundred miles an hour and and and he you
said I want to talk about the problems
cuz a surprising number of people were
like yeah that sounds like a good idea
let's do that and then they were they
were reaching out to me and saying we're
having D sinks where quad is falling out
of the air when I go above 70 percent
throttle and I was like yeah of course
it is what are you what are you nuts
these 6s 2700 kV what did you expect to
happen I don't know I don't know how
anybody and you said let me tell you all
about it so Brian herro welcome to
welcome to the show thanks so he's
always gonna be come on Tommy indeed
it's been too long actually so so what
how do you howdy
well let's start with this question when
you have a 2700 K V motor on a 6 S
battery why is that a problem
sure well there's couple of reasons
if you think about it your your rpms are
gonna be a lot higher than than what
they would be on another setup so higher
rpms mean the ESC has less time the
detective zero crossings means that
there's you know there's a lot more
happening a lot more quickly in ESC also
you end up with transition spikes in
terms of current changes in current
current Delta that's going to be a lot
higher than what you get on on some of
these smaller lower kV motors simply
because remember KB is per port
shanell to the torque constant torque
constant says how much current does it
cost me to make torque so when you're
doing very rapid changes in rpms that's
requesting a lot of torque which means
that it's going to create a lot of
current moving through the coils in the
motor so all those things combined
together you know mean that you're gonna
have higher noise levels and DSCs which
again complicates detecting that point
where the magnet passes the coil at the
peak point with what we call a zero
crossing right zero crossing they can't
detect that zero crossing accurately
then it's not going to know when to fire
the next phase and it can do that a
couple of times and just kind of guess
in he okay right you're crossing after a
certain number of times the ESC will
just know the analogy I that sort of
made this clique for me is I think about
like the merry-go-round in the
playground and your kids on the
merry-go-round and you grab the bar and
you give it a whip and then as the next
bar approaches you grab that bar and you
give it a whip but if you were to just
stick your arm out the bar would crash
into your arm and you can break your arm
and that's a desync as the motor spins
the magnet rotates past the poles and
the ESC needs to drive current through
the through the stator such that it
pulls and pushes at the exact right
moment
and what you said really I didn't really
think about this and although it's
obvious when you say it the faster the
motors spinning the less time there is
to detect the approaching zero crossing
and then like make all the things happen
that need to happen the current to rise
in the magnetic field and so forth we're
talking about these things are so
processing you know really fast compared
to what you think of in terms of human
turn so even then it's generally you
know the timing isn't as big an issue
but when you start talking about ten
times in the window between the dead
time and land you know what can actually
fire it's just everything gets more
compressed and you know there's more
chances of something going wrong
particularly given the fact that a lot
of these is seized I mean
I'm not dogging on manufacturing but
we're hobby great meaning factual great
we're not masturbating so when when
we're talking about the type of
variation that they have in the
components that are being used we have a
fairly large window of variation so if
the dent time is slightly off based on
you know they have a manufacturing
specification that's saying the dead
time should be within this window based
on these parts but if the parts are
slightly different and that dead time
gets a little bit out you know off you
can end up with you can know things like
shoot through being coming more of a
problem that's not as much an async
problem but if the dead time isn't
optimized you end up with more noise
than you see which get impact how you
read what what is dead time if for
people who don't know what what's dead
time in a in an ESC so dead time has to
do with the amount of delay that it puts
between when one half of the phase those
often the other one comes on so when
you're dealing with it's a basically
it's a an h-bridge essentially if you're
familiar with electronics at all where
you have a high side and the low side
thing so the dead time has to do with
how much time it gives for the for the
current to dissipate between turning on
one eye or turning off the high side and
turning on the low side or vice versa
because it can turn them both on at the
same time you effectively do a short
circuit that allows current to just like
then you try your motor which ends up
increasing heats and causing all kinds
of problems
I remember back in the day I had had
some machines that where the dead time
was incorrect and they they would heat
up like blisteringly hot within a few
seconds oh I guess it would fry the ESC
because you'd have a short-circuit into
the inside the ESC correct you you want
a short circuit through the motor
because that drives the motor yeah so
the dead time and the dead time is
important because the FETs which are
just basically tiny little electrical
switches that switch current switch
voltage or current on and off the FETs
don't turn on and off instantaneously
right that's why you need the dead time
there's always there's gonna be some
window where the FET is kind of like a
little open and a little closed and you
don't want what's called shoot through
is that is that what the name is for
that short circuit is shoot through okay
so yeah it's again it it has to do with
how the gate line is designed what
capacitance is on the gate line you know
there's all kinds of just small things
about how the ESF design we can change
what the ideal dead time for that is
obviously we want the shortest possibly
at any time that we can get to allow the
fast as possible switching great but you
you know you don't want to cut it so
close that you're you're causing problem
so right the manufacturers are supposed
to provide those dead times to the
firmware developers right obviously if
they there's been a couple of situations
that that we've run across recently
where the dead time that they were
providing was not necessarily accurate
or they would they would make a modified
version of the firmware themselves and
the dead time label and the firmware was
one thing but then they went into the
code and hard-coded change to it that
made it look like it was something else
so what happened is when people upgraded
the firmware they Friday yes see right
so the manufacturer was so so we've got
a situation here where the manufacturer
designs the esc and it sounds like they
design it with a certain rpm range in
mind and it makes me wonder if if I mean
is dead time something that we could
change as a user we could go well I'm
gonna mess with it and make my esc less
likely to desync or fry when I run 6s
2700 kv so back in yes days yes because
the dead time multiplier was part of the
firmware exponent and it was open source
so you can just change it no I mean you
just watch a different version of
firmware okay you would choose like you
know what was it like gee age 30 and so
the 30 was the dead time multiplier so
you could go to gh 40
you know solve your problem if you were
getting he assumes that we're heating up
through the to look that time now this
thing really you shouldn't go into six
that shouldn't cause a problem with dead
time because dead time should stay
relatively the same regardless but if
the dead time is off already going to
success may exacerbate existing
especially because as he said earlier
there's a certain amount of variance in
the components that's used in you may
just have gotten unlucky with a fete
that's particularly slow to turn on or
off it's on the gate line that's out of
spec you know that's that's the big one
is these little SMD caps the big use in
a lot of our low end electronics
manufacturing stuff are they D rate like
crazy I mean the the rating window on
those things I'm crazy well we wouldn't
want to pay two four two four tenths of
a cent instead of one I mean come on
it's just the way they're made you know
the the ceramic capacitors you know the
tolerances are not but yeah I mean when
you're making a lot of stuff I guess the
cost so so we've talked about that
they're they're higher rpms results in
more sensitivity to mistiming
missing the zero crossing or the having
shoot through and also increases noise
electrical noise which also makes it
more difficult to detect the zero
crossing is that the issue then when you
go to these high rpms it becomes more
difficult to detect the zero crossing
and know when to sort of drive the coils
is that what it boils down to I think
the torque constant of a higher kV motor
also plays because you're getting you
know it's costing more current to
produce the torque which is creating
more ripple you know current red ball
well let's let's talk about that there's
a there's a cop because one of the
questions people have asked is could I
go 6s 2700 kV and then use a motor scale
to scale it down so I effectively have
the same rpm
at the prop as if I was like 4s 2300 and
I said well I've done that and it kind
of works but then why don't we all just
use a let's just take it to the extreme
why don't we use a 10000 kV motor with a
20% throttle cat why not why not Ryan
well the torque constant is the answer
to that question within the range of
things that were typically using on on
our mini quads the torque constant is it
varies but it's not nearly as wild as if
you had like if and as you're saying
it's 10,000 order so the torque constant
again relates to how much current it
costs to produce torque so again when
you're flying at a fairly constant
forward speed write the torque request
isn't a whole lot so the differential
between division efficiency and
interesting the normal constant forward
speed is not dramatic I mean it's there
you're gonna interesting if you go into
a higher kV
noter but it's not genetic like you know
a couple of percent thing okay but
that's not really where it plays a big
role it's more where when you're making
rapid changes in throttle when you're
hitting those high angle of attack of
maneuvers where you're basically moving
backwards and right why the other
direction so right when you're really
putting a lot of torque strain on the
motor when there's rapid changes that's
when you're gonna see the spikes in
current again you're not even ever gonna
see those even in your in your logs in
your flight controllers because we're
not we're not logging at a high enough
rate when you say spikes he means spikes
in their like the milliseconds or
microseconds yeah level 1 to 2
millisecond range like when I'm testing
on the bench I'm recording I'm recording
I know it's like every I think every 2
milliseconds I have a sample that's
coming in I can go down to 500
milliseconds or microseconds ethanoic
and I've done that and looked yeah it
usually the spikes usually last for
maybe just a single sample when I'm
sampling at that great but those are
even on a normal setup you know normal
maybe normal voltage you're looking at
you know they can be upwards of 160
hundred 70 amps or you know on a single
motor record for that tiny fraction of a
second this is something about the esc
ratings that is often missed by people
especially when they're starting out
which is you have a 30 amp rated esc
well that's continuous you can burst for
10 seconds maybe 2 40 45 amps but what
people really don't realize is that
there are fractions of a second of
spikes in the hundreds of amps for a
very short period of time and that's all
sort of soaked up by the capacitance in
the circuit and the battery but but
those spikes can be enough to damage the
esc and damage the fed's
depending on various factors really the
you know in that regard and this is
going to be true with the high can be
higher voltage setups even more than
traditional set up since that it's when
that motor gets blocked when it's trying
to spin you're going to blow up because
that's when the torque demand goes right
up doesn't there you go you're getting
software installed for exactly I mean
it's gonna fry everything that's that's
fascinating so I'm very familiar with K
V which is the voltage constant is that
the right Nitori term the K and I think
most people are familiar with K V is the
relationship between the supply voltage
and the RPM that the motor tries to make
I'm less familiar with the torque
constant but that's a very interesting
idea and that really helps fill in that
gap which is that the higher kV motors
people say higher kV motors have less
torque that's not true but higher kV
motors need more current to make the
same torque and if you assume that
current is not unlimited then
practically speaking a higher kV motor
may make less torque and if it makes the
same torque it's going to be more likely
to like try something yeah so and this
is the
the reason why people think that a
higher capable order makes less torque
is because they're operating by the
wattage limits of the motor so basically
a higher cable order has a lower torque
ceiling or within the wattage limit
because because you don't have unlimited
power if you had unlimited power then
you could run a 10,000 kV motor on a 20
percent throttle cap and you wouldn't
notice the difference but you'd be
drawing a lot more power right so what
happens is basically the high kV motor
will burn itself out from the current
cost of the torque production before the
locating murder but people get confused
because they hear that and they think
that a lower kV motor is going to be
able to spin up a prop faster than a
high kV mode
because it oh it's got more torque but
it doesn't have more instantaneous
torque interesting it's not actually
like if you look at the rate of change
of rpms right way don't you have your
rate about the same assuming all the
other design characteristics are the
same like magnetic field strength gap
between the stator and the magnets you
know all of that stuff that impacts the
actual instantaneous torque of the motor
this if it's the same between motors
you're gonna get very similar results in
terms of how quickly need the prop is
changing our hands if it's the same prop
on both motors with the same requested
throttle G right until you hit the power
ceiling and the power ceiling in a
quadcopter
it seems to me like you have a d50 to
find number one as the point where you
just draw so much current that you smoke
your motor or number to the point where
your battery just gives up and cries
uncle right in 90% of our cases the
current delivery capacity of the battery
is the living effect does that mean but
then then so we're getting a little bit
off topic of success 2700 K V I want to
come back to that but we always range so
many interesting places does that mean
that people that success low kV I mean
when we go to 6s low kV we've got a
lower kV and a higher voltage so that
should mean that the
torque constant is lower and we get more
torque for less watts is that correct
yes no I mean you're also dropping the
kV so there are other things that go
with that
but yes in general a a higher kV or
lower kV motor on higher voltage is
going to have a lower torque constant
which means that those current demands
are less assuming the same
characteristics now that a little bit is
misleading because oftentimes even at
lowered Katie the combination of gave me
in Baltic is still higher rpm that's
true then what a take if you take like a
24 50 kV 4s motor the equivalent rpm if
you're at success is like 1666 I think
yeah I'm not doing it's either 24 50 or
2400 but most people don't run 1666 kV
for us a success
they run 1750 or 1800 and they're
getting more rpm so it doesn't quite
even out so what can we do then we know
like why high kV high voltage causes
problems what can we do to go to not go
160 miles an hour and not desync sure so
there's a couple of settings that you
want tune in your ESC is when you're
dealing with high K th 2 to kind of give
yourself the best chance of not having
trouble so I generally recommend a set
of parameters some of them you can just
sit and forget some of them you're
probably going to want to - and that's
one of the reasons why I wanted to talk
with you today is to walk through like
how to tune that because it doesn't only
apply to high KB high voltage high KB a
high voltage exposes the need for it
more than anything else but this can
also be a useful tool to - tuning other
setups as well we don't often think
about tuning our e to see settings when
we're tuning we that's true we tune the
flight controller and just I mean a lot
of people leave me this news once
or they have set parameters that they
change every time right like that
I usually go Auto to Auto timing in 48k
PWM but I don't really like tune that I
just like okay it seems good right so
what I usually will recommend to you the
higher higher kV the best shot is turned
demag to high number one now you may
have some performance losses in some
areas as a result of these changes
because basically what we're doing is
we're trying to back off the
instantaneous acceleration you see the
point where we're not causing trouble
and we're reducing those current limits
reducing the noise factor so the other
one is fixing timing at between 23 and
25 degrees basically removing the the
parts of the code in the ESC are not
calling the parts that those that are
doing that our timing calculation so
then you're getting rid of some of the
CPU overhead and you're always by
increasing the timing the higher the
timing advance rate advanced degree
advanced on the less likely you are to
gain decent the more ahead of time your
firing on that right the less chance
there is music again you're gonna lose a
tiny bit of efficiency but you're also
dating back a tiny bit might work I
think if you're running 6s 2,700 kV
efficiency is really not your priority
now to compensate for for that and so
the dimag high in combination with that
setting and then the one that you really
consumed and this is this is the one
that's really the most interesting I
think is the ramped up our so in our ble
series when we were talking about this
we talked about the brief but basically
I've done a bunch of testing on ramp up
our or startup power as it was called
previously in in previous versions of
the ability so this has to do with the
maximum rate that it allows the ESC to
change the PWM duty site so it's
basically limiting how quickly it can
jump duty cycle on the fence so that you
can reduce that pretty dramatically
before you start seeing any
noticeable change and how quickly the
motor changes are ends basically what
we're hearing is we're reducing that
current dump that happens into the coils
in that moment between when we requested
Donal change happens and when physically
the motor starts spinning fast that's
interesting because the motor can only
change speed so quickly because it is a
physical object with mass and inertia
and so it's it reminds me of like if you
have a really like an underpowered car
and you just step on the throttle and
the engine goes the car just doesn't go
anywhere and it slowly starts to pick up
speed and eventually it gets up to 60
miles an hour but you even just kill it
redlining the engine the whole time as
opposed to if you kind of like just just
baby it a little it'll get there just as
fast but you won't stress it as much is
that that fair right so the goal is in
tuning grandpa power is to reduce it to
the point where you get the best
reduction in that peak current in that
one millisecond range without actually
having any noticeable performance loss
right what I'll usually do is back it
off until I notice the difference
and then increase it slightly again
until that difference is gone
I think bi-directional D shot probably
is gonna because you have a thrust and
set up that most people don't have but I
think bi-directional D shot may be a
good tool to help with that because it's
giving us a thousand times a second or
something whatever the D shot rate is
it's giving us the instantaneous rpm of
each of the motors and it's a very
useful tool if you're into blackbox
logging to be able to look at the
response time of the motors box and
their response the response graphs
they're okay to do some of that as well
basically back it off until you start
seeing decreased response or ingesting
bounce times and then pull it back up
again but honestly even there unless you
I would say unless you're noticing a
difference in the tune or in the field
of the sticks even if there is a slight
difference in big toolbox or in in the
RPMs if you're not able to detect it as
a pilot it doesn't really matter
yeah for sure you know I I would say I
don't even usually bother hearing any of
that I just pull it back until I can
feel the difference but let up until I
can't hear it
what's the default value for this but it
wasn't again ramped up power as a deeper
ammeter 50% is the default value for
AMPA and I start out by dropping it to
25 just right off the bat and you don't
even notice a difference and I usually
can't notice okay interesting well and
especially if you're trying to do one of
these really radical builds like if
you're falling out of the sky at 70
percent throttle then maybe giving up a
little bit of responsiveness is an
acceptable trade-off that's how it
sounds like demag - hi do you met
conversation - hi timing you said 22 23
degrees timing oh sorry
23 - 25 degrees timing and ramped up
power reduce it just start by knocking
it down to 25% and then maybe even go a
little further than that right basically
you're having the same problem just keep
dropping it until the decent pro all
right what about
PWM frequency so some people have said
they changed PWM do you think that what
kind of effect do you think that has so
yeah
is a really tricky one because PU PWM
frequency has a ton of variation
depending on the specific motor the
specific PSC and you know how the RPMs
relate to the the commutation rate and
the throttle you know and put all of
that stuff those all overlay on each
other to kind of interact with how PWM
rate works so in some cases you'll see
dropping to 24 kilohertz section solve
some problems yeah you'll see the same
problem solved by going 48 kilohertz
it's true things where it could go
either way you just have to kind of test
it and see I was helping someone tune in
a pod that they were having some bloke
rattle off vibrations on the other day
and it was this is this is the craziest
thing so they were having low throttle
vibration and we completely got rid of
it and they dropped their drop to 24
kilohertz everything was everything was
good and then they crashed no no and
after the crash the quad wanted to just
take off to the moon and they couldn't
do anything about how they went back to
48 kilohertz and this problem went away
and everything was fine let's that's
crazy I've been hearing people but for
something about beta flight 4.2 is
bringing out low throttle instability so
the Deaf's we're not this week yeah and
are there making recommendations that
people who are running 48k pwm go down
to 24k because the lower PWM frequency
gives slightly more torque and give it
at low throttle specifically and this
this actually is what cute me in on to
the solution on this ayat so I had a
bunch of quads in three gray back at
like 4 4.0 and previous to 4.0 and then
I have a bunch of them that's like
really good on on 4.1 4.2 4.0 with the
rpm filter but I had several where I
could just they just always had these
these low throttle or you know come
low-end
just they just start to move around that
you get because they find before
yeah though on these quads before I
would get in when I was tuning I would
get into this loop and I'm sure you've
experienced this in the past where when
you're tuning race pee but you start
getting some weird bounce back some you
raise D and then great yeah you start
chasing P and D so I always had to run
lower P than what I was necessarily
happier with on those builds because I
would get into that into that cycle of
tuning that would just run away so I
could get them to fly good in my 3.5
unfairly low key games
but then I was thinking about why would
going to 24 kilohertz solve the problem
for some builds and why and I started
talking with some other guys who are
tuning particularly guys who are tuning
on large squads at 6 inch 7 inch and who
had gotten really good tunes without a
lot of the shapes that are that are a
problem on those builds and like
something just clicked in my head and I
started playing with it
so when rpm filter actually kicked in
it changed some things about how we turn
because of the way the filtering was
being we have a clear signal we can we
can change the way we tune again when
that happened I never really went
through a full retuning process - I just
got my same numbers on there and never
really changed it so here's the thing
though the RPM filter and all of this
better filtering has really eliminated
that issue with the peed bounce back and
chasing P and D so I went back in and we
tuned everything and upped my p games by
like 50% all of those oscillations
disappeared like that that's interesting
well problem it sounds like I mean if
you increase the P gain that will
increase the response of the pit
controller and get the motor out of that
low torque low rpm region faster I
suppose it's just giving it more more
control at that low end point and then
responding more quickly and you know I'm
kicking myself for not realizing this
sooner because I mean you and I remember
tuning back in the multi weekdays right
and we used to call it dump truck you
remember where you get your gains were
to go in your gym and I'm like I hadn't
had to deal with that and so long but
like I didn't make that connection in my
brain but basically what we were doing
with dr. it is a pretty interesting well
that's that's really cool right that's
that's the answer
running P gains up in this like
mid-sixties
and I've been helping people tune in
some 7-inches that are running P gains
up into the center
Wow and all of that all of those
struggles we had with the large prop
sizes causing all kinds of new issues
I think we're related to number one the
frames being physically larger which
changes the relationship with the FIDs
the props being physically larger still
changing speeds slower and like you get
into this mindset though I can't go too
high because they produce more dress so
I shouldn't need more Keegan's but P
gains are all on that initial
acceleration and that's where they
really need that boost to be able to
stabilize better that's interesting
that's interesting the P the yeah
because the the larger props will
respond slower so you need that higher P
even though that may be making more
thrust overall you may need that higher
P gain de to get that acceleration going
at the same time we're talking about
lowering the ramp up time to help reduce
the demand for acceleration but that's
that's once in the flight controller and
ones in the ESC so I guess they're not
the same thing well if you know that if
you start noticing bad characteristics
on ramp up our you want to fart because
the goal is to pull back the current
dump you to the coils in the ESC without
actually changing the rate with the es
right right you're not just sitting
there screaming at the the motor the you
know when it can't accelerate any faster
than it already is you're just gonna
dial it back right to match the
capability of the motor to change that
has a big impact on production see back
saying we can get cleaner video by
lowering a ramp up our butt no that
makes sense because the when the motor
changes speed if the ESC demands more
torque then the motor can possibly
respond with then you'll get these big
current spikes and that makes video
noise that's interesting and you know
even just the inductive nature of that
current being stopped suddenly you all
of the lines in the system you know and
then you've got voltage fluctuations as
a result current draw shifting rapidly
so you're seeing both voltage
current you know fluctuations creating
BMI in the system so yeah in general its
its if we can reduce the initial spikes
of current in that where where Clint
cleaning up the entire thing that's an
even has a bigger impact in 401 the
issues where you have all 40s season a
single ACP again you know that's gonna
have a bigger impact on EMI and things
like that it makes me wonder though why
do they ship it if you're saying that
you could probably lower it to 25% on
most builds without ever noticing a
difference why do they ship it at 50
well you have to think I mean yes a lot
of these EEOC's are for mini quads but I
mean we're a tiny section of the Hobby
that uses the SC's you know so I don't
know that I think for for maybe for some
other applications it might be different
you know I don't I don't
could you speculate what kind of
application would need a higher ramp up
time any smaller motors that are able to
that's the real kicker would be like
1507 god some of the really tiny
stuff you may actually you know I have
been played with it that's a lot of my
best but there may be reasons to go the
other way on some of these really small
right I guess is it's you're trying to
think you're out you're trying to find a
balance between the motors ability to
change speed and the ESC s demand that
the motor change speed if the ESC is
just demanding more speed than the more
change in speed then the motor can
provide then you get current spikes if
the ESC is not driving the motor
aggressively enough you'll get less
responsiveness so theoretically people
with smaller motors if they were to
increase the ramp up time maybe they
could get a little more responsiveness
with no real downside mm-hmm yeah it's
one of those tricky things because I
know people have been disabling braking
on some of the really small setups you
know in order to solve some of that
current dump issues so I like it might
be interesting to play with some of
those settings that in those small
environments and see how all right well
great
now we have the secret and any other
settings that you can think of that
people should be noticing sounds like
the big I think we knew the guy who
built my quad phantom FPV he goes by he
did the demag and he did the timing but
he didn't mention I don't remember him
mentioning changing ramp up time ramp up
power anything else because I think a
lot of people don't really know what it
does but yeah it's it actually I think
it's one that's probably one of the more
important ones to and play with the
mixing of some of these as far as you
might be able to reduce ramp up our but
then turn demag back to low yeah just
kind of play with some of the
combinations to see where that sweet
spot is and where you're doing the most
to eliminate GMAC situations without
without causing any problems in in terms
of vsi's response time
yeah cool I appreciate you reaching out
to me with this because like I when
people ask questions I like to be able
to help and I like to be able to answer
them and I really have had nothing like
I'm like I don't know that we're so far
beyond the pale with these quads I have
no idea what to recommend so it's great
that I now have like one thing one more
thing to recommend which is adjust the
ramp up time I would say that I have not
seen very many cases where Napa hour
doesn't solve the desync issue but
there's something one one word of
caution with this is that
when we're pushing the limit on setups
like this sometimes it will expose bad
hardware and what we can end up doing is
putting a band-aid over bad heart so
yeah how do you work yeah good it may
make it work but you may be covering up
that are ha that's a I'm glad you said
that because I meant to ask you this
earlier but then we just got distracted
how can people recognize a good ESC that
is more likely to work other than just
like looking at like we know that there
are certain EEOC's like phantom used the
t motor at 55 a I've heard people using
the hobby wing and say they're good
things about it the hobby weighing 60 M
how can people is there some carrot some
speck or characteristic people can look
for that will say that an ESC might be
more likely to tolerate this kind of
treatment
I mean yes but without getting into a
lot of looking up the specific events
that are on it and looking at the baby
shoots and yeah you know RTS on x and
and things like that but even there you
would have to know more about how the
circuit was designed around those bets
to really be able to predict it well but
if you just look at the fence and look
at the actual data sheet on the FET it's
gonna tell you a lot about kind of the
limits of what that is produce what kind
of what kind of spec so for people who
are who are dedicated enough to do that
what kind of specs would you be looking
at on the datasheet so you want to look
at the thermal dissipation capacity of
the of the package like it'll tell you
what the thermal dissipation limits are
and also you want to look at both the
sustained current ratings and the peak
current ratings and they actually have a
pulsed current rating is really a good
thing to look at to they they can tell
you what those kind of instantaneous
Peaks are usually they're in a 200 amp
range and that's really kind of what you
want to look for but you could you can
end up getting you know yes but the
first thing we want to do is just find
the actual FET and you would need to
like find a photo maybe at the esc and
like look and see if you can see the
label or you buy it and they're stamped
on there but and the audience on time
you know as far as the gate the gate the
time it takes the gate to turn on and
actively bet the lower that time the
better but there's you know even that is
subject to some interpretation because
it's it's depend a lot of that depends
on the rest of the circuit that's in
mind with the with the you know with the
gate line right right and that's where
you know you get into some really
interesting stuff you start diving down
these data sheets because if you start
looking at it on paper those metal fence
that they're using on some desire yes
you actually don't look very good on
paper in terms of you they have slower
RDS on times and there's there's some
things that make them maybe not the best
bird what we would think of in our
normal
many caught applications but they appear
to do okay in practicality so yeah I've
heard some I've heard some criticism of
some of the rosiest
those fats saying they have dated like a
higher resistance and they're gonna suck
more heat at which counter some people
have made the argument and I don't know
if it's true that in in certain
applicant high-current applications the
fact that they're metal so they can
dissipate heat easier is offset by their
increased resistance and it sounds like
it is in fact over a pretty deep rabbit
hole
all right all right well Ryan are really
let me go back and answer that one yeah
yeah but because I think the one thing
that is is worth looking at when it
comes to an ESC is getting involved in
the community and asking what has worked
for other people yeah because that's
gonna tell you things that a Danish
can't I mean obviously you should take
that with a grain of salt because some
people have only ever tried that one yet
you know people people say racist aureus
these are so good I've never had one
fail and I'm like it reminds me it
reminds me of that you know the game
it's not a you just pull a card out of a
deck you say Ace of Spades is that your
card no well if you do that 52 times you
just do that all day eventually you'll
get one right and so somewhere out there
there's a person who's bought 20 racer
star EEOC's and not a single one has
failed just statistically doesn't
necessarily mean the racer starts the
best ESC right and that's why it's
important you know when you're looking
at qualitative analysis you want to get
a broad range of feedback from the broad
range of environments so like asking a
lot of different people and getting
information from a lot of sources you
can start to put together a kind of a
qualitative picture of which eosin stand
out above the others in terms again
general community air in mind also that
there's more to manufacturing than the
datasheet you could have the best specs
in the world but if you have poor
quality control you're gonna make junk
and that's where those the there are
there are many many good EEOC's out
there but I always have my ear to the
ground for the ones that seem to really
excel and
the two that stand out to me are the T
motor at 55 the T motor have 45 but it's
not a foreign one and the hobby wing 60
M those are ones that just people I know
who beat the hell out of their gear just
say that they are really really solid
pretty much across the board any any uh
once you can think of that you feel like
are probably pretty reliable I fly
probably 90% econ stuff so I really want
to be a con 35 amp individuals I tend to
go individual route because I feel like
I have more control over the noise floor
put a cap on each ESC and just in
general I feel like I end up with a
better quality tuning more and more with
individual rather than foreign once the
time but yeah I have I do that being
said I have a couple of builds with the
a con 55 in our family a con 35 and 4
ones that I've been able to tune in
pretty well and dialed in so those are
those are kind of my go-to but and
actually you know we I have not heard
many of those failing either so just in
general yeah but there are other you
know there these days I think just
there's a lot of really good stuff on
the market and we we're in its time
period where a lot of it is pretty
decent I mean you can get you can get a
pretty broad range especially when it
comes to the motors these days I mean
like yeah motors are babies are pretty
pretty solid there's some pretty good
motors at a pretty decent price all
right Ryan well thank you very much for
just randomly saying hey I want to talk
to you please do it anytime I have so
much fun when we talk and I always learn
I always learn stuff so now I'm I'm
gonna be playing with ramp up power on
my on my quads and seeing what I can do
with them I'll be curious to hear what
you okay awesome
Brian's website is mini quad test bench
comm where you do the most in-depth
motor testing of anybody I know anything
else that you've got going on that you
want to plug you have a frame don't you
that you actually sell that are you just
make it for yourself in your basement
well
I've gotten into frame design a lot and
doing a lot of contract work for some of
the major Beauty companies out there
doing a lot of your contract design that
kind of stuff but it's fun I enjoy the
design aspect that's probably where I'm
spending most of my time these days is
doing okay all right man well thank you
very much happy flying everybody what
are you still doing here the video is
over
do you watch all the videos all the way
to the end wow you are a super fan
thank you that me actually helps the
channel a lot when you watch the videos
all the way and YouTube gloves that you
know what else YouTube loves when you
subscribe or when you join my patreon
for as little as two dollars a month or
more if you feel like I've earned
actually YouTube doesn't like you to
join my patreon they don't get a cut of
that